every single human being has value and
my value is not determined on how I look
or what job I have you know so many
people put me down and say Nick you look
too weird and no one's really a friend
and you can't do this and you can't do
that and for three months he would chase
after me and say Nick go speaker speaker
go speak and I said no no no no no and
finally he twisted my arm I said yes and
it takes three seconds for me to tell
you something discouraging but then you
may never forget my words he's an
Australian Christian evangelist and
motivational speaker he was born with a
rare disorder which left him without any
arms or legs he founded attitude is
altitude a secular motivational speaking
company he is Nick voyage and here is my
take on his top ten rules for success
number two is my personal favorite and
make sure to stick around all the way to
the end for some special bonus clips
every single human being has value and
my value is not determined on how I look
or what job I have or where I'm from
where I was born how much money all that
stuff is nothing so many teenagers you
know tease each other for how we look
and I tell the teenagers do you think
that I'm cool enough to be a friend
they're like yeah of course so but I
have no arms no legs they said doesn't
matter said really so it doesn't matter
that I have no arms no legs I said no it
doesn't matter I said then actually if
it doesn't matter then why do we kill
each other with our words if it actually
doesn't matter why do we look ourselves
in the mirror and see ugly instead of
valuable I want to ask you today what
are you looking for if I gave you a
billion dollars would you be happy if
you gave me a billion dollars I'd be
very happy but then if my mum dies
tonight am I happy No
with all the money in the world I'll
never be happy Mike because money is
something that cannot heal the soul you
know so many people put me down and say
Nick you look too weird and no one's
really a friend and you can't do this
and you can't do that and I couldn't
change anything I don't like just fixing
my hair one day and everything's fine
it's not like you know just whatever I
couldn't change my circumstance I could
have just one day wake up and say hey
give me arms legs I need arms legs and I
mean like oh we went to a bodybuilder
you know and said can you make me some
arms and legs I'm Jackee bodybuilder you
get it right this is hey you know I got
to be able can you give me a hand you're
not just joking here but it was so hard
because people put me down
and I started believing that I was not
good enough I started believing that I
was a failure they'll never ever be
somebody who people would like or people
would accept and it was so hard man I
thought to myself I you know I can't go
on to go on to a soccer field like
everybody else and I can't ride my bike
and I can't skateboard and all these
sort of things and I started getting
depressed I thought what kind of purpose
do I have to live I mean do you are you
just here to live to die I mean is there
not a purpose for me is there not a
purpose in life and I had questions and
no answers and asked my mom and dad why
did this happen I asked doctors why did
this happen they don't know there are
some things in life that are out of your
control
that you can't change and you're going
to live with the choice that we have
though is either to give up
or keep on going I want to ask you what
are you going to believe are you going
to believe in yourself you're going to
believe everybody else's judgment on you
are you going to believe people when
they say that you're a failure no one
really likes you don't really cares
about you it's not really to say that
hey you need someone to come up and say
hey really I I like you I care about you
no it's not that but it's the fact that
people put you down people don't even
look you in the eye people ask you how
you are and you say fine but you're not
fine and they'll know don't ever know
that life is life life is is an
interesting journey of ups and downs
but how that journey ends is up to you
today you see when you fall down and you
feel like giving up when times get tough
it's not the end the question is are you
going to finish strong the definition of
a disability is something that will
hinder you from being able to do
something I think though the greatest
disability is not having no arms and no
legs the greatest disability is your
mind the choices that you make the
question is are you going to make the
right choices are you going to make the
choice to have your life in it's right
perspective are you going to make the
choice to get up instead of give up are
you going to make the choice to dream be
there is no greater disability that we
have in our life then to make the
decision to give up because once you
give up then there is no hope but until
you give up there is that hope do you
think I'm gonna love my son even though
if he one day wanted to be a CEO and
becomes a janitor at a college yeah you
want to know why cuz a janitor changed
my life he was the first guy who said
hey Nick
you're gonna be a speaker and I said mr.
Arnold you're a crazy old man
I said what am I gonna speak about he
said you're gonna share your story I
said I don't have a story he says yes
you do I said no I don't
he said Nick you know what you're here
in high school you gotta go speak at
that spiritual group I'm like no way am
i doing that no way I'm not speaking to
those ten people I'm not gonna go to the
Christian nerd section and for three
months he would chase after me and say
Nick go speaker speaker go speak and I
said no no no no no and finally he
twisted my arm I said yes
and I went there and I spoke for a
couple minutes and I saw her go cry and
I'm like are you okay she said I said
what's wrong she said I said why you
crying she said I was just touched I'm
thinking who touched her I tell you life
is interesting life's a journey see this
phone here let's say that I want to go
to the phone right and I start from over
here now to get to the phone it's not
like I'm going to start meditating and
going hum write and float across the air
right there's something to sort of work
it's not like I'm gonna go hum and you
know it's not going to work so I have to
take one step at a time one step at a
time one step at a time you can only
take one step at a time I don't care how
big your step is it's only one step at a
time you can't do two steps in one
understand so it's like one step at a
time and you take steps in this
direction you take steps in that
direction sort of get lost along the way
and sometimes you fall down now to
illustrate my point I'm going to jump
off the table door back twist and land
on the floor okay is that cool are you
ready but there's a clock there okay can
you move the clock for a second please
beautiful beautiful all right you ready
so are you guys ready just let me know
when you're ready are you ready okay
ready one two I'm joking man ladies is
just put the clock back there if I did
that I'll break my arm or something your
honor mean but honestly along the way
you might fall down like this ready
yeah hello
so what do you do when you fall down get
back up everybody knows to get back up
because if I start walking I'm going to
get anywhere but I'll tell you there is
some times in life where you fall down
and you feel like you don't have the
strength to get back up you so you sort
of put a mask on your face when you come
to school and pretend that everything's
okay when it's not and you go home and
lay in your bed when no one's looking at
you when you don't have to impress
anybody and you're yourself and fear
comes in you know the fear that you have
as soon as you walk into the doors of
your house maybe there's a broken home
maybe you have doubt in your life maybe
you don't know if for sure what's going
to be happening in the future and it
scares you maybe about maybe you're
worried about what people think of you
what people say about you just that fear
paralyzes you and I just want to ask you
today do you think you have hope because
I tell you I'm down here face down and I
have no arms no legs it should be
impossible for me to get back up I mean
you go home and tie the legs and arms of
your brothers and sisters and like push
them down and see how long it's going to
take him to get back up you know what I
mean
you know you can tell them that you'll
see them tomorrow you're not I mean but
this is the thing it should be
impossible for me to get back up but
it's not you see I will try 100 times to
get up and if I fail 100 times if I fail
and I give up do you think that I'm ever
going to get up no but if I fail I try
again and again and again for as long as
I try there's always that chance of
getting up does that make sense and it's
not the end until you've given up and
just the fact that you're here should
persuade you
that you have another chance to get back
up there's still hope I'm not here today
to tell you that I understand your pain
I don't know how it feels to be abused I
don't know how it feels to feel quote
fat and you've got an eating disorder I
don't know how it feels to have a broken
home I don't know how it feels but I now
first have a broken heart and I have
feels to be alone and I want you to know
that I found my strength in Jesus Christ
and you're going to find your strength
in whatever you find it in but I just
want you to know that it's not the end
it matters how you're going to finish
are you going to finish strong and you
will find that strength to get back up
like this
my passion is to encourage people to
inspire people to be all that they can
be I found my purpose I found my
strength and I want you to find yours
don't be afraid of failing every time
you fall down every time you fail you
learn something new you're ready for the
next one you've learned how not to do
something well then learn from it and
move on leave ones behind and press
forward you can only win if you don't
give up go for it
don't let anything hold you back if
nothing's holding me back what's holding
you back I want to make sure that every
single day that you are alive that you
make it count and you take the sweeter
choices of life that God has given you
because I want to ask you right now if
this was your last thirty Seconds to
breathe how would you be remembered well
you're a giver encouraged or where you
were taker will you a better person did
you encourage people to in your actions
in your life did you help them or did
you discourage them did you take that
time to say hey how you doing and they
look to the ground and say all you know
I'm okay now look at me how are you
doing we are here for one another this
is the ministry this is Jesus this is
the light and I want to tell you I'm
sure that if any one of us were as was
at a road and there was a three year old
kid in the middle of the street sitting
down playing with rocks on the street
and a bus was coming and the bus was
about to kill him you have plenty of
time to get up off your seat go save
that kid will you say that kid of course
you will you don't know his name you're
gonna save that kid you don't know his
religion you're gonna save that kid you
don't know his sexual orientation you're
gonna save that kid because what we are
the light and love in the bridge to
Jesus Christ we need to understand that
it's not just doing what we think we
need to achieve or have some people
think that things get easier when you
get married I'll go talk to some married
people
some single people I like I'm not happy
but I know I'm gonna be happy when I get
married dude if you ain't happy single
you ain't gonna be happy married can you
hear an Amen yeah you guys already know
it right you got to talk so what do you
want how do you act who are you make
today count dream big and never give up
the world is a hurting place and the
world needs hope and the world needs
love without hope we feel like why are
we you well brokenness here's mine today
I still have no arms or legs but
everything's changed everything for me I
was looking for hope and happiness and I
couldn't see it for many years in fact
if this side of the table represents my
hope truth encourages me to become all
that I can be but then we have lies
every day coming in our mind
people who discourage us you know the
people that you have in your life who no
matter how good of a day you're having
they'll bring you down or and no matter
how bad of a day you're having they'll
bring you even lower you know what I'm
talking about
think of the three biggest discourages
in your life they're not your biggest
discourages you are you are it only
takes three seconds for me to tell you
something discouraging but then you may
never forget my words I've met so many
50-year old women and 40 year old women
who still remember what their fathers
told them that they wish they never
heard words are powerful when you hear
those words and then your mind starts
growing with these lies Nick you're not
good enough Nick just give up Nick
you're never going to get a job you
won't get married you can't even hold
your wife's hand what kind of a father
are you going to be if you can't even
pick up your kids when they're crying
you're alone I'm sure your parents hug
you but their hugs can't heal you just
give up just give up
just give up just give up just give up
at age eight I thought that I should
commit suicide why I didn't have hope I
thought I didn't have hope today you can
see that I had hope what's the word
believing in something you do not see
faith words can only do so much
hugs can do much more than words but
when hugs can't do anything that's where
faith kicks in for me words and hugs
were not enough but I had no faith there
are times in life where you don't see
the purpose or the good in your
situation but just because you can't see
it it doesn't mean it's not coming who
goes to the train station looks down the
railway in tears aren't the trains light
here I'm leaving you will wait for the
train why because the schedule says that
the train is coming so just because you
can't see the hope in your situation it
doesn't mean that it's not there you see
many people think that I have only one
foot just because you can't see the
other one I've gone from a life without
limbs into a life without limits what
about you the world is a hurting place
in the world needs hope the world needs
love my parents always taught me that
even though we don't know why I was born
this way that we have a choice I did to
be angry for what we don't have we'll be
thankful for what we do have
I'm here in Slovenia I am so amazed the
trains here are so so fast you see that
one's insane so
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because max GTS II asked me
to so if there's a famous entrepreneur
that you want me to profile next leave
in the comments below and I'll see what
I can do I'd also love to know what your
next top ten rules have the biggest
impact on you and why leave in the
comments and I will join in the
discussion and finally I want to give a
quick shout out to Karen Seth yeah Karen
thank you so much you're buying a copy
my book it means a lot to me so those
are you watching if you want your chains
at a shout-out in the future video make
sure to pick up a copy of the book and
email in your receipt so we can keep
track thank you guys so much for
watching and continue to believe or
whatever your one where it is and I'll
see you soon
hi everyone its NIC voyage here you'll
never believe what we're doing today
we're here in dallas-fort worth with
American Airlines we're doing something
that I always entertained in my mind to
try doing and that's the dress up in a
pilot's uniform and greet the passengers
as they get on the plane
courtesy of captain Glenn Thompson with
captain Glenn Thompson what are we doing
today
well Nick what we're doing is we're
filling Nick's dream about being an
airline captain we're on flight 2574
dollars to LAX and we're going to have
you up there greeting your passengers
and you're going to do inspirational
motivating talk to everybody and you are
going to be the man today is important
to you today doctor you're the captain
those flight I heard Nick had a dream to
be an airline counts and I saw him
speaking at Lakewood Church with Joel
Osteen and I saw speaking and I actually
brought tears in my eyes and I said I
can make that happen in America Airlines
is the company to do it and we're here
today to fill your dream Nick well your
dream I can't believe it's happening
that's right
oh my board I'm your captain today I
think for you to chow we're trying out
some new technology have a have a great
great flight I'll talk to you soon all
right Thank You captain big pleasure
gonna be fine be playing today there are
some you technology which are yeah you
do that
how good really fun here all the way
from Dylan can you do it yeah oh man I'm
woozy
nothing yeah what's more freaked about
me plunder playing the fact that I'm
policies or the fact that happen along
fella your knowledge
good class that you'll never build
before I might speak one fly
enjoy
give me a
he's acknowledged
doing really well little nervous my arms
are sweating okay
trying to mutate common today I'll be
fine play I'm excited oh yeah blue is my
music it was activated control oh great
great weight off of my head
we just boarded the whole plane it was
really funny some people their life okay
some real life really like are you
controlling now brainwaves I have no
idea kids like what some people define
cool you were you were talking about the
new technology what did they say
just total is this guy really slider
play because he doesn't know what he's
talking about they're like so they're
like why you sure
you know that oh my god this guy's
taking to the air he's telling me this
melody stop this
it was great thank you let's let's greet
the passengers
new technology that we have your first
captain without arms or legs flying
right we have some great new brain wave
technology
I just pray that either get you
distracted
just do what I do hold on
okay
what is your like what did you want to
do like oh my gosh
of the technology let's go
you take me